[Musique]
bonjour ou re bonjour a tous notre
dimanche spécial législatives se
poursuit sur france 3 franche comté en
partenariat avec l'astre républicain et
france bleu besançon nous sommes
toujours en direct toujours dans le parc
de la gare d'eau à besançon et après les
débats entre les candidats des deux
circonscriptions de l'agglomération
comtoise ce matin on va partir
aujourd'hui dans deux autres
départements cet après-midi dans le jura
tout à l'heure avec la deuxième
circonscription du jura celle de
champagnole saint-claude et puis tout de
suite la haute-saône didier fohr de
l'est républicain est avec nous il va
nous rejoindre dans un instant mais je
me tourne tout de suite vers david mal
qui va nous présenter à les candidats
mais avant que l'on parle des candidats
david la première circonscription de
haute saône c'est tout simplement celle
de l'ouest du département entre vesoul
et gray une circonscription qui vous le
voyez à pour sortant le député lr alain
chrétien il ne se représente pas on y
reviendra
et puis cette première circonscription
de haute saône elle a voté en faveur de
marine le pen au premier tour de la
présidentielle près de 30% des voix vous
le voyez devant emmanuel macron et
françois fillon jean luc mélenchon suis
4e avec un peu plus de 15% des voix
didier fohr de l'est républicain donc va
nous rejoindre mais d'abord david qui
sont nos candidats et bien jérémy avec
nous nous avons marie breton la
suppléante du député sortant alain
chrétien
1 marie breton lr l'est républicain
première adjointe au maire de grey sur
notre plateau également à dimitri
doussot il est maire de vos concours
nerveuse 1 il ya l'investiture l'est
républicain udi avec nous également pour
débattre aujourd'hui
léonie cugnaux elle est la candidate du
front national elle n'a aucun mandat
elle a déjà été candidate au
départemental et aux dernières et
régionales face à elle et pour parler de
cette circonscription
on trouve également barbara beso ballot
elle n'a aucun mandat elle est la
candidate la république en marche
bonjour et
si elle est novice en politique son mari
ne l'êtes pas parce qu'il est maire de
marne est avec nous pour débattre
également françois froidurot le candidat
de la france
insoumise lui non plus n'a aucun mandat
c'est sa première candidature aux
législatives et il est donc le candidat
de la france
insoumise et puis pour terminer ce tour
2 plateaux eh bien nous sommes avec
laurent ricard le candidat du parti
socialiste
il n'a aucun mandat et c'est sa première
candidature aux élections législatives
sur cette deuxième sur cette
circonscription donc de haute saône
première la première voilà sont
également sur cette preuve elles sont
également candidats sur cette première
circonscription philippe bazot du mei
rémy brenets sans étiquette martin
buffet upr thérèse gare et lutte
ouvrière
corinne lyonnais pour europe ecologie
les verts marquent mantovani pour debout
la france et cyril boulleaux du pcf
allez marie breton on démarre avec vous
ce débat vous êtes au party les
républicains
la suppléante du sortant le député alain
chrétien et pourtant vous n'êtes pas
investi par votre parti est ce que vous
payez la votre proximité avec bruno le
maire écoutez moi actuellement je suis
suppléante du député républicain alain
chrétien
nous nous avons fait le travail sur le
terrain pendant cinq ans l'investiture
officielle moi j'ai la légitimité du
terrain c'est la légitimité qui compte
c'est d'avoir fait le travail sur le
terrain pendant cinq ans d'avoir été
présente auprès des gens auprès des
agriculteurs auprès des industriels
cette légitimité là que je veux avoir
bon vous ne répondez pas à ma question
est ce que vous payez votre proximité
avec bruno le maire il ya certainement
des choses qu'ils se décident à paris en
catimini qui ne sont pas forcément
correspondance effectivement à ce que
les gens les républicains du terrain
attendent
j'en conviens et c'est peut-être ça que
les parties paye aujourd'hui dans le
résultat des élections c'est qu'il
n'écoute peut-être pas assez justement
ceux qui sont sur le terrain
marie breton alain chrétien fait partie
des élus locaux qui ont appelé leurs
formations politiques à répondre à la
main tendue les manuels macron quel
député serez vous si vous êtes élu ferez
vous partie de la majorité
présidentielle là aussi je vais être
très clair je pense qu'il ne faut pas
faire de chèque en blanc au président
emmanuel macron il faut pas non plus
être dans l'obstruction systématique
moi je veux être dans la construction
dans la proposition pas de chèque en
blanc pas d'obstruction systématique
donc et vous avez soutenu un candidat à
la primaire qui aujourd'hui est au
gouvernement
j'ai soutenu un candidat à la primaire
qui est aujourd'hui est au gouvernement
et ministre de l'économie en plus donc
effectivement c'est important je pense
que pour la haute saône ça peut aussi
être une chance il faut pas s'en priver
dimitri doussot vous êtes maire d'une
petite commune donc de haute saône
investi officiellement par le parti des
républicains
pourquoi avoir contesté la légitimité du
duo sortant alors tout d'abord précisons
une petite chose c'est que la légitimité
du terrain ça s'appelle l'élection
l'élection s'est déroulée 18 juin c'est
pas pour l'instant par rapport à votre
question pour répondre assez simplement
alain chrétien renoncé très normalement
très légitimement à ne pas se
représenter et il me paraissait assez
normal de dans un parti politique ou
sein d'une démocratie comme la france et
puis savoir différentes candidatures
investiture on sait qu'alain joyan d
alain chrétien sont pas les meilleurs
amis du monde
vous avez été l'assistant parlementaire
d'alain joyandet
etes-vous le candidat d'alain joyal et
pour embêter alain chrétien
alors pour vous répondre très
franchement est très directement je ne
suis ni candidat d'alain joyandet ni
candidat de michel raison ni candidat la
binette
je suis le candidat dimitri dussault qui
est le seul souhait terrain j'ai pas
besoin de tuteur
j'ai pas besoin on va dire de marabouts
derrière moi j'ai un garçon et je pense
que toutes les personnes qui me
rencontrent le terrain où se rend le
corps de ma détermination de mes
convictions et se rendent compte au
final j'étais je suis suffisamment
libres et indépendants pour icloud qu'à
aller les honey cugnaux vous êtes
également candidate à ce poste de député
en haute saône
oui la haute saône qui a porté très haut
marine le pen lors de la présidentielle
vous estimez que vous pouvez être une
députée de la majorité frontiste à
l'assemblée nationale mais écoutez je
pense que tout est possible marine le
pen a fait 46 46 % au second tour de la
présidentielle dans ma circonscription
donc la première circonscription de
haute saône je pense qu'effectivement il
ya une majorité de patriotes dans cette
circonscription et que nous pouvons de
toute façon oui créer une majorité avec
notre chef de file marine le pen dont
certaines cohabitation une cohabitation
avec le gouvernement de voir philippe
moi j'appellerai peu plus tôt soit une
opposition crédible elle
c'est l'opposition possible à ce
gouvernement qui va causer beaucoup de
misère sociale dans les années à venir
cette circonscription faisait partie des
circonscriptions ou debout la france et
le front national pouvait s'entendre
finalement vous partez divisé malgré le
rapprochement à la présidentielle est ce
que vous le regrettez non je pense que
nous avons choisi de conserver chaque
partie son indépendance
juriste on marque mantovani le disait
sur france bleu il était possible il
était envisageable que debout la france
et le front national et des candidats
communs c'est pas le cas oui tout à fait
comme dans beaucoup de circonscriptions
nous pouvions effectivement penser qu'il
y aurait eu les accords et qu'il y
aurait eu un candidat commun mais
finalement ça sinon ça ne s'est pas fait
et bien écoutez une porte ont chacun
encore pagne de notre côté mais ça
n'empêche pas
le fait que nous ayons des idées
communes et la fibre patriote barbara
vaisseau ballot vous êtes donc candidate
dans marche
inconnu du grand public ou presque
comment gagner une crédibilité de député
en trois semaines de campagne seulement
eh bien écoutez
effectivement je suis âgée j'ai 45 ans
j'ai une famille de trois enfants
je viens je suis né à marne et j'ai
habité chasse et laisser à côté de ces
sur saône j'ai depuis je suis marié à 21
ans
à l'âge de 21 ans je suis toujours resté
à marnay donc je suis effectivement
connu de ce monde là dans lequel j'ai
toujours été j'ai été pompier quelques
années et ça il faut que je puisse
effectivement le faire valoir dans les
trois semaines qui restent mais vous
avez l'essentiel est souvent invisible
on a entendu marie breton dire que elle
restée ouverte par rapport à aux
gouvernements d'edouard philippe est ce
qu'il y a deux candidates en marche sur
ce plateau
j'entendais marie breton dire tout à
l'heure je suis très clair pareil je
suis très clair je suis là candidats qui
étaient investis le jeudi dernier par le
mouvement en marche parmi les deux neuf
mille candidatures les 427 choisi il y
en a une qui a été choisi pour la
première circonscription haute saône
c'est la mienne
barbara abel ce ballot vous êtes dans
une circonscription rurale emmanuel
macron a fait d'excellents scores dans
les villes ce que c'est compliqué d'être
la candidate en marche dans un monde
rural
je crois qu'il faut entendre la colère
de tous il ya une colère qui s'exprime
et pire il ya une colère qui ne
s'exprime pas celle là il faut avoir le
courage de la regarder en face et il va
falloir les entendre et on a beaucoup de
travail effectivement pour arriver à
reconquérir cette partie qui ne croient
plus à l'ancienne politique françois
froidurot vous êtes donc le candidat de
la france
insoumise c'est votre première
candidature aux législatives
vous y allez pourquoi sur cette
circonscription en haute saône eh bien
écoutez moi j'y vais d'abord j'y vais
pour c'est cela c'est le leitmotiv de
tous les candidats sur ce plateau c'est
sortir le petit livre l'avenir en commun
le programme l'avenir en commun qui a
recueilli 7 millions de voix avec jean
luc mélenchon à la l'élection
présidentielle et la deuxième raison
c'est que dans ce pays les ouvriers et
les employés représentent 50 % de la
population à peu près moi je fais partie
je suis assistant familial
j'ai un salaire au smic et je trouve
scandaleux qu'il n'y ait à l'assemblée
nationale que moins de 2% de ces
catégories qui représente la moitié de
la population néanmoins françois
froidurot dans cette circonscription
jean luc mélenchon réalise
c'est moins bon score en franche-comté y
acculer dans le haut doubs qu il a il a
fait moins bien
comment vous l'expliquez trop rural pour
jean luc mélenchon je ne pense pas que
ce soit la vraie raison la raison ces
femmes même si c'est lié à cela c'est la
puissance du vote front national dans
les campagnes donc le front national
répond mieux aux interrogations aux
angoisses des oubliés je pense
précisément qui ne répondent pas mieux
la preuve c'est que au fond et c'est ce
que j'explique aux habitants des
campagnes moi-même j'habite un tout
petit village d'une centaine d'habitants
vers jussé je leur explique qu'en ayant
voté marine le pen en définitive ils ont
assuré l'élection dans un fauteuil de
monsieur macron dès le soir du premier
tour
au fond le front national est l'idiot
utile du système
laurent ricard 6e candidats sur ce
plateau candidat investi par le parti
socialiste mais vous vous présentez dans
vos publications comme le candidat de
tous les progressistes
on y revient un troisième candidat en
marche absolument pas du tout je pense
qu'il ya une chose qui est progressiste
c'est un peu élevé dans l'idée
progressiste on est d'accord qu'il ya
une logique qui est très importante qui
est de dire que on vit mieux que ce que
nos parents ont vécu et la problématique
du programme d' emmanuel macron c'est
que il y à un certain nombre de choses
avec lesquelles je on peut être d'accord
effectivement mais il ya aussi des
choses avec lesquelles je ne suis pas
d'accord et en particulier je pense
qu'il faut le dire 60 milliards d'euros
d'économies supplémentaires et notamment
tapé encore en plus sur les communes
cent vingt mille fonctionnaires postes
de fonctionnaires supprimés c'est à dire
un fonctionnaire sur deux c'est ni plus
ni moins ce que nicolas sarkozy a fait
pendant son mandat
je pense que pour la ville nos campagnes
pour la vie de la ruralité ce sont des
solutions et des propositions qui n'ont
qu'un seul qui n'auront qu'une seule
finalité malheureusement c'est de faire
monter le front national
et je crois que l'on doit absolument
lutter lutter vraiment contre ça et je
les dis dans les autres publications
dont vous parlez le front national c'est
mon ennemi et lorsque je
travail mais vous êtes très chaud ça
fait en attendant ça fait sourire léonie
cugnaux et oui mais si je peux si je
peux terminer juste là dessus la haute
saône c'est un département industriel
c'est un département qui dépendent
l'export énormément et lorsque l'on voit
les solutions qui sont proposées par le
front national notamment en termes de
fermeture de frontières termes de sortie
de l'euro quand je rencontre des
salariés notamment j'ai visité j'avais
pâturages comtois qui sont des
entreprises sur le territoire audois que
vous devez connaître qui elles ont
besoin de l'export et ont besoin de
l'euro et donc je suis là moi de mon
côté pour représenter ce que j'appelle
cette gauche progressiste mais qui a
encore une capacité à faire avancer
progresser les choses merci laurent
ricard merci david on va faire rentrer
sur ce plateau d'i d'efforts de l'est
républicain bonjour didier vous avez
choisi d'interroger nos candidats sur
une thématique propre à cette première
circonscription la ruralité
alors la ruralité haut on voit bien ce
qui se joue sur la carte de cette 1ère
circonscription haut saônoise au second
tour de la présidentielle le vote front
national se cristallisent dans les zones
les plus rurales et quand on parle aux
habitants ils se sentent délaissés
oublier des classes et c'est la france
des oubliés qui va falloir aller
chercher dans cette campagne à qui on
peut poser la question c'est à vous de
choisir
alors peut-être à léonie cugnaux oui
quelle est la question est ce que vous
allez chercher cette france déçu d
oublier comment vous allez les chercher
tout à fait vain de toute façon c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis le départ c'est un
succès le socle principal de notre
programme je pense que nous sommes les
seuls à apporter les bonnes solutions à
savoir le retour à la souveraineté nous
quelle grande souveraineté sortir de
l'union européenne ce qui est
indispensable
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure on va
faire
m'a fait sourire mais aussi rire jaune
parce que je les politiques qui sont
menées depuis plus de 40 ans par la
gauche et par la droite n'ont rien
apporté à part la misère les
agriculteurs se suicident de plus en
plus mais ça vous en parlait pas est ce
que vous savez combien l'europe apporte
l agriculture en haute saône en
particulier est ce que vous connaissez
un chiffre allez-y dit le nom d'allah
déjoué halak est ce que moi je vois tout
ce que je vois c'est ce que l'europe
nous prend est ce qu'il nous redonne
mais qu'est ce qu'elle apporte aux
agriculteurs donner le chiffre mais je
n'ai pas à répondre à votre question à
l'aider vitry douce au monde à effectuer
sur l'altération de la ruralité
agriculture et oui la ruralité la
campagne de façon générale parce que
j'entends beaucoup de gens parler de
ruralité
sauf qu'à priori je suis peut-être le
seul avec notre collègue de jean luc
mélenchon à vivre dans une commune
rurale à vivre dans un village des 130
habitants où je suis né où je suis maire
depuis un certain nombre d'années
j'habite marne et oui mais bon c'est
déjà un bourg c'est le plus important
j'habite à une paroisse on va faire
aller commune d'habitation tout le monde
je sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de
d'agglomération et de ville en haute
saône voilà un bon c'est pas même
réalité
mais pour revenir sur la ruralité
souvent ce que les gens ont l'impression
c'est de ne pas être considéré regarder
pendant cinq ans le déménagement du
territoire qui était mis en oeuvre on a
fermé un collège à champlitte c'est les
socialistes au pouvoir un département on
a réformé tous les cantons les gens ne
s'y retrouve plus on a modifié les
périmètres intercommunaux
les gens s'y retrouvent plus assez de
problèmes comme star mais lui-même c'est
extrêmement important c'est d'aider vos
solutions dit la très simplement on
commence déjà par considérer les gens
pour le monde agricole on arrête de les
embêter on arrête de mettre de mettre
des normes supplémentaires des
contraintes supplémentaires
quand je vois nicolas willot qui
rentrent au gouvernement je suis
extrêmement inquiet pour les élus ont
commencé leur redonne un petit peu de
liberté parce que je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance aux territoires
il faut faire confiance à l'intelligence
de ce qu'ils sont on va dire élus
responsables économiques habitants pour
savoir s'il veut le faire ensemble pas
faire ensemble à leur donner des moyens
un euro pour la ville et dois je vous
avais devrait donner un euro sera quant
à lui françois frein durant problèmes de
la ruralité moi je pense que la première
qu au trou de la désertification de nos
campagnes c'est l'agriculture chimique
industrielle qui sévit depuis des
décennies
la concentration de plus en plus des
terres dans les mains de quelques-uns et
je pense que la principale réponse à la
revitalisation des compagnes c'est de
changer de modèle agricole
l'agriculture bio et créatrice d'emplois
lorsqu'on pense et je termine sur ce
point la france
historiquement une des principales
puissances agricoles d'europe et même du
monde est aujourd'hui dans une situation
d' importer 70% des produits bio qu'elle
consomme c'est absurde c'est un scandale
et donc il faut relocaliser et produire
bio dans notre pays pourrait prendre au
besoin
alors peut-être qu'il faut quand même
ajouter parce que je crois qu'à une
question qui reste sans réponse c'est
que 80% de la production agricole haut
saônoise part à l'exportation et en
dehors de france voilà fallait le dire
marie breton on parle de petits quand on
parle de la ruralité je voudrais
justement intervenir là dessus parce que
la ruralité certiat l'agriculture mais
ce n'est pas que ça ce n'est pas que les
petits villages non plus c'est tout
notre territoire qui rural les petits
bourgs les petits villages les espaces
ruraux sans la ville préfecture ne
fonctionne pas la ville préfecture sont
les petits bourgs ne fonctionnent pas
non plus et un ensemble et c'est ça qui
fait la fragilité notre territoire et sa
force c'est qu'on fonctionne tous
ensemble dans la ruralité
il ya aussi des entreprises il ya aussi
des artisans il faut pas les oublier les
petits commerces de proximité les
problèmes de santé c'est ça la ruralité
c'est tout cet ensemble qui forment les
composants de la ruralité
j'y tiens particulièrement l'agriculture
j'ai eu le soutien des gens de
l'agriculture qui sont venus le
président la chambre d'agriculture est
venu apporter son soutien je les connais
je l'étais rencontré j'étais présente à
toutes les assemblées générales mais y'a
pas que c'est un ensemble c'est pour ça
qu'avec alain chrétien on a défendu les
gp cancoillotte lundi géographique
protégée parce que c'est tout un
ensemble c'est bien sûr la filière
laitière
mais c'est aussi ce qui fabrique comme
mort on sait aussi ceux qui travaillent
autour comme pago capitaine john deere
c'est tout ça la ruralité ne nous
trompons pas c'est un ensemble ses
différentes composantes
madame b saint malo vous avez dit qu'il
fallait entendre la colère il faut
entendre la colère des ruraux on va dire
qu'on va dire exactement
voilà oui qu'est ce qu'on fait il faut
remonter longtemps la formation aussi il
faut travailler avec le terrain pour
faire remonter l'information
effectivement il ya cette colère
scolaires aussi chez les agriculteurs
chez plein de monde
cette colère là alors on a parlé
d'agriculture on parle pas mal
d'agriculteurs effectivement c'est un
sujet majeur dans notre circonscription
il faut un salaire juste des revenus
juste mais quand même ça il ya le succès
moi mais ça ce sont des mots comment
vous verrez une réalité aussi
économiques
c'est à dire que quand hier j'étais à
port-sur-saône faverney et quand il y en
a greater mieux que nous avons visités
oui en bio le lait et payer un peu plus
cher c'est très bien il arrive tout
juste à en vivre
on parle pas de vivre décemment il avait
sali fois rival changé cependant il ya
une autre réalité derrière économique
on va parler on va discuter par nombre
de nos très belle entreprise comme chez
venir est par exemple il faut que sois
compétitif aussi pour rester numéro un
sur la pâte molle en europe il faut
c'est toute une filière qui est à revoir
maintenant j'aimerais parler par rapport
à l'art et à la ruralité ya les rythmes
scolaires dont il faut qu'on parle une
école interne aussi les villes mais ça
concerne aussi les villes
une école a chassé les cgt dans une
école unique
j'ai eu le même professeur de la
maternelle jusqu'au cm2 donc je sais de
quoi je sais de quoi je parle dans le
vécu mais une les réalités d'une école
de chasse lycées n'est pas la même
qu'une école en centre de vesoul
il faut pouvoir répondre et plus coller
au terrain sur icar peut-être que la
terre internet bien entendu le
désenclavement de notre territoire aussi
j'en ai parlé longuement hier avec les
élus qui se trouve à port sur saône
ça fait circuler la centrale monsieur
ricard la la recomposition politique
actuel qui donne un peu le vertige
il faut quand même être clair est ce
qu'elle est elle ce qu'elle peut
apporter une réponse aux territoires
ruraux
alors moi avant on a abordé quand même
plein de thèmes il ya plein de choses
qui ont été abordés
j'aurais juste revenir je pense qu'on
partage à peu près tous le même le même
constat sur ce qui se passe sur nos
territoires
maintenant il ya des solutions concrètes
qui existe et je pense que c'est ça que
les citoyens attendent dire que moi
depuis le mois de novembre
je suis rentré en campagne j'ai été
désigné par les militants du parti
socialiste j'ai travaillé je suis allé
sur le terrain j'ai rencontré le milieu
associatif les chefs d'entreprise je
crois qu'il faut proposer une solution
très simple et très pratique sur le sur
la ruralité ont notamment sur la
désertification
sur les déserts médicaux je pense qu'il
faut proposer un véritable bouclier
rural
c'est très simple c'est une mesure qui
est proposé notamment dans le conseil a
des dents un conseil départemental qui
propose tout simplement garantir un
minimum de services publics dans les
bourgs centres obligatoire et sa l'état
doit investir les collectivités
publiques peuvent le faire donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné on doit proposer
des solutions très simples très précises
et très concrètes je prendrai le juste
l'exemple des déserts médicaux lutter
contre les déserts médicaux ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire avoir des maisons de
santé ça on le fait déjà
sauf qu'on sait qu'en france il en
manque approximativement 1200 donc ça
veut dire que par exemple sur le
département de la haute saône ça
pourrait être 5 6 maisons cinq six
maisons de santé supplémentaires
c'est la fin du numerus clausus pour
amener des médecins dans les
supplémentaires et les faire venir
effectivement dans dans nos territoires
ça c'est très important et c'est des
solutions très concrètes très précise le
dr rioux juste pardon jeu pour vous
redonner la parole pour que ça soit
équitable cette colère elle va pour vous
se concrétiser où elle va se disperser
avec on va dire un peu l'effondrement
entre les entre les présidentielles et
législatives du vote front national
non moi je pense qu'au contraire elle va
se concrétiser puisque là nous sommes
nous parlons du territoire rural nous
sommes sûrs que chacun se dit candidat
sur la même circonscription qui est
totalement rurales et les gens ont des
attentes et savent très bien que comme
dans le congé de marine le pen nous nous
attaquons à tous les problèmes qui se
rapporte à la ruralité
nous aussi nous nous luttons contre la
désertification nous voulons revaloriser
les services publics dans l'est dans les
communes les plus rurales nous voulons
veiller à ce qu'il y ait une totale
égalité sur le territoire c'est très
important que autant qu'il y ait autant
que ce que nous pouvons avoir pour la
politique de la ville vit également une
politique de la campagne et ça ne
pouvait le mettre en place dans un pacte
par exemple pour la ruralité
merci léonie cugnaux merci didier
on vous retrouve dans quelques minutes
sur l'autre circonscription celle du
jura et puis david mal va nous rejoindre
[Musique]
alors david vous avez bien écouté
attentivement nos candidats quel point
souhaitez vous approfondirez avec qui on
vient on va passer sur la petite phrase
de pas là pour jouer au professeur et à
l'élève
je vais d'abord demandé à monsieur
doussot de nous dire pourquoi il a grand
peur de nicolas hulot dans le nouveau
gouvernement d'edouard philippe nicolas
hulot que nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac
ont rêvé d'avoir dans leur gouvernement
alors pourquoi pourquoi vous avez peur
de la présence de nicolas hulot
tout d'abord la présence de nicolas
hulot ça monte sommes déjà que le
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui c'est un
gouvernement de casting cinq événements
télé réalité on met des personnalités
qu'on pèche un peu partout tester ce vol
commun on peut s'interroger temps les
assauts pôle nucléaire d'autisme et
nicolas hulot bon moyen exactement je
viens aujourd'hui l'agriculture français
souffre d'un excès de normes de
contraintes administratives de sueur et
d'augmentation par rapport à union
européenne est aussi que nicolas hulot
qui est vraiment une étiologie sts va
certainement pas leur faciliter la vie
c'est tout ce genre j'ai sur le terrain
en retour du matin au soir puisque moi
je je rencontre debout toute personne
durant toute la journée
est ce une dégustation peccolo bacs pour
le monde agricole effectivement pas
seulement de rituels aujourd'hui
souffrent on est en train de réformer
d'un lourd dispositif est peut-être
effectivement que si on leur simplifier
un petit peu la vie qu'on supprime un
certain nombre de règles
peut-être qu'il s'en sortir un petit peu
mieux elle peut-être qu'il aurait un peu
plus de marge de manoeuvre et de
compétitivité par rapport aux états
européens
j'ai bien noté - normes pour
l'agriculture haut saônoise merci
monsieur rousseau madame beso ballot
vous avez dit il faut des salaires plus
juste alors pour votre parti en tout cas
la république en marche
est-ce que d'après vous il faut laisser
faire le marché ou réguler le marché
parce que ce dont souffrent les
agriculteurs français et haut saônois
c'est la volatilité des prix les neuf et
régulé je suis d'accord avec que ce que
disait monsieur ricard sur les le droit
à la médecine
non mais il est cher au marché je suis
d'accord sur réguler le marché
effectivement ou sur les inquiétudes qui
peut y avoir sur les sur l'écologie et
il va falloir qu'on continue à être
compétitif c'est vrai
une chose est essentiel à mon avis c'est
d'abord créant de la richesse pour mieux
le distribuer derrière c'est à dire ah
on n'a pas le droit de parler de
dépenses sans richesse ça c'est quand je
suis à gauche et mon j'ai toujours été
de centre gauche se mange jamais encarté
parce qu'il y avait ça qui me gêne et on
peut pas être généreux sans argent
créons d'abord ses richesses libérons c
est spécial c'est mon premier objectif
et ensuite nous pourrons nous permettra
d'être généreux ensuite nous pourrons
nous permettre de distribuer il n'ya que
ça comment pouvons nous nous permettre
de distribuer s'il n'y a pas de richesse
auparavant
marie breton vous avez noté donc la
réponse de la candidate en marche
d'après vous si vous êtes élu député
demain dans dans l'assemblée nationale
de demain
est-ce qu'il faut réguler le marché pour
permettre aux agriculteurs d'avoir
comment ils le connaissaient avant des
quotas ou est-ce qu'il faut laisser
faire ce qu'il faut c'est travailler
avec les agriculteurs c'est les entendre
ils nous le disent tout le temps ne fait
pas sans nous arrêter de nous donner des
directives qui viennent de paris et qui
ne sont pas faites avec nous ils veulent
qu on le construit avec eux il faut les
écouter c'est pour ça que je veux créer
un groupe de députés ruraux à
l'assemblée nationale qu'ils puissent
être les porte-parole à paris et non pas
le contraire il faut pas que sa descente
de paris chez nous c'est à nous de
monter à paris ce dont nous avons besoin
monsieur ricard vous nous avez dit il
faut un bouclier rural
on a tous en mémoire la venue de
françois hollande un conseil des
ministres exceptionnel à vesoul
concrètement on en retient quoi de ce
conseil des ministres qui est venu en
haute saône sur la ruralité
moi je vais plutôt parler d'avenir si
vous j'aimerais plutôt pour répondre à
mes questions
écoutez je pense qu'à un moment donné
effectivement il ya un travail qui a été
fait par rapport à des solutions très
précises et très concrètes moi ce que je
voudrais simplement par rapport
à l'avenir et notamment cette idée de
bouclier rural parce que moi elle me
tient à coeur
donc je vais en parler parce que c'est
quelque chose de très important pour moi
on le voit en milieu rural les
problématiques et moi je le fais je fais
le diagnostic depuis le mois de novembre
depuis que je suis sur le terrain le
sentiment d'abandon est quelque chose de
fort chez nos concitoyens et notamment
au milieu dans les villages monsieur
nous a parlé tout à l'heure qu'il était
issu d'un village me suis je suis
originaire de jussey où les services
publics oulémas les magasins ont fermé
dans les années 80 comme sur un certain
nombre de territoires donc on doit
réinvestir le territoire et ça ce sont
des solutions très président est très
pratique en réinvestissant mais c'est
vrai qu effectivement un moment donné si
on veut des solutions
eh bien il faut investir sur les
territoires n'y a pas de choix si merci
pour votre réponse
continuer le tour de tabra les ans avec
avec monsieur froidurot je vous propose
cette même question que vous avez dit
faut plus faut plus d'écologie il faut
investir dans l'agriculture bio bien
entendu il faut même que ce soit la
priorité absolue en ce qui nous concerne
dans notre programme nous proposons la
création la création de cinq cent mille
emplois dans l'agriculture bio l
agriculture bio est une agriculture de
manoeuvre il faut rompre avec the lady
la concentration des terres faut revenir
à une agriculture familiale bio et
paysannes
mais pour cela il faut rompre avec les
traités néolibéraux de l'union
européenne léonie cugnaux à un dernier
mot sur le thème de la ruralité
vous êtes certaine de capter l'électorat
rural
oui tout à fait nous nous proposons de
valoriser les communes c'est à dire
qu'il faut revaloriser les rôles rôle
des maires des petites et moyennes
communes
nous ne voulons pas avoir un échelon
totalement européen avec des méga région
l'europe et des intercommunalités en bas
et pourtant la pac c'est max et ça mc
celle qui sert à avoir un revenu pour
les agriculteurs c'est l'europe
et bien c'est pour ça que nous nous
étions pour une politique agricole
française comme le système et en
terminer avec la pac vous voulez la fin
de la pac la politique agricole commune
oui mais ça mène à une tête et une
totale destruction je veux dire moi j'ai
discuté avec des agriculteurs ils n'en
peuvent plus et comme le disait monsieur
d'où son nom la pac la pac je pense que
quand ils ont peuvent plus de la pac
c'est ça que vous êtes en train de dire
non moi je disais qu'ils ont pu lui dès
12 ans de liam que le rôle inverse
allez on va passer très vite avons
maintenant attendez attendez d'abord
parce que leur avance juste une question
très précise à dimitri doussot et marie
breton avant la conclusion vous êtes
deux candidats les républicains un
officiel une dissidente
si l'un est devancé par l'autre est ce
que vous vous désister forcément entre
les deux tours dimitri doussot vous
réponds très franchement que d'une part
si j'avais fait investi je ne serai pas
candidat ça c'est important
et deuxièmement bien entendu bien
entendu si je ne suis pas devant je
serai pas candidat au deuxième tour
marie breton
il est bien évident que je ferais la
même chose très bien laurent ricard
autre conclusion en 30 secondes ont fait
un dernier tour de table alors comme
j'ai dis donc depuis novembre 2016 je
travaille je suis sur le terrain je suis
candidat j'ai fait un diagnostic mais
qui est de qui vient de très loin parce
que j'étais candidat aux élections
départementales et j'ai travaillé sur le
le canton de vesoul 2 dans le cadre de
la majorité départementale avec yves
krattinger j'ai pu aborder avec les
citoyens des thématiques sur l'emploi
sur le logement sur la prise en charge
de la vieillesse en milieu rural qui
sont des thématiques dont on n'a pas
parlé et et j'en ai déduit qu'il fallait
vraiment imposé un bouclier rural c'est
ce dont je ce dont j'ai parlé je serais
parti - d'un groupe autonome à
l'assemblée nationale qui soutiendra les
projets qui sont des projets innovants
et progressistes mais par contre qu'ils
sautent qui sera quand capacités
proposées comme ça ça n'ira pas dans le
sens du progrès merci monsieur monsieur
froidure votre conclusion 30 secondes ma
conclusion est bien je dirais qu'en
définitive monsieur macron l hologramme
de messieurs sarkozy et hollande réunis
avec la cravate de monsieur gattaz les
chaussures de monsieur jonckheere et sac
à main madame merkel et moi j'appelle
les électrices et les électeurs a refusé
cette politique est envoyé une majorité
de la france a soumise à l'assemblée
nationale merci barbara besson ballot
j'ai envie de répondre nous avons passé
le temps d'être contre soyons pour voilà
ce que j'ai déjà envie de répondre c'est
bien beau d'être contre qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour construire demain qu'est ce
qu'on va faire ensemble
il y a avant des sports moi je suis pas
comme dimitri c'est vrai sur ce point de
vue là j'ai jamais été aussi fier de la
france qu'en ce moment
quand on va à l'étranger on peut y aller
la tête haute
ne loupons pas se capte la ne repartons
pas dans les travers justement qu'on a
vécu dans les tricotage et l'idée de
tuer l'otage constant donc pour passer
dans l'espoir aux actes il faut donner
une majorité absolue une grande majorité
le
juin est pas plus tard c'est le 11 juin
qu'il faut voter pour que ça change
réellement qu'on passe de l'espoir aux
actes léonie cugnaux oui eh bien moi je
pense que nous sommes aujourd'hui face à
une telle recomposition de la vie
politique que nous annonçons d'ailleurs
de plusieurs gènes année le clivage
gauche droite n'existe plus d'ailleurs
on voit pas pour même vous votre
suppléant il dit vous représentez ennemi
honda centre est de 800 cas de la droite
vous êtes prête à vous rallier la
politique macro dont clairement ce qu'on
voit c'est que le front national est la
seule opposition crédible et qui pourra
défendre la france et les français
puisque nous ne sommes pas là pour des
intérêts personnels pour l'intérêt de la
france donc il faut plus que jamais
défendre la france et je compte sur les
électeurs pour se tourner vers le front
national
dimitri doussot votre conclusion 30
secondes très rapidement très rapidement
dont j'ai été désigné par les
républicains l'idée pour présenter
officiellement à droite et le centre
c'est avec fierté et humilité mais aussi
responsabilité que je présentais valeur
de cette famille politique pour le
redressement de la france et pour lui
rendre ses revendeurs faites attention
ne pas voter pour des personnes dont les
choix politiques sont actuellement assez
cher
ne votez pas pour une personne qui est
dissidente est il déjà annoncées tel
recours est assez rapidement derrière
emmanuel macron mois chutant de la
droite républicaine pour une droite
forte pour une france forte
votez pour moi si vous souhaitez une
conviction une valeur soit représenté
dignement un sommet national marie
breton
oui donc effectivement il ya des
candidats qui sont là depuis cinq jours
d'autres cinq semaines moi ça fait cinq
ans que je suis sur le terrain à suivre
les dossiers
je veux une haute saône ancrée ancré
dans le 21e siècle
alors c'est sûr je veux être à
l'assemblée nationale pas forcément dans
l'opposition mais pas faire de chèque en
blanc non plus hors de question ce que
je veux c'est défendre la ruralité
parce qu'avant tout je suis haut
saônoise et 7,7 ruralité là qu'il faut
défendre et mettre en avant il faut en
être fier merci à tous les six je vous
précise que sont également candidats sur
cette circonscription philippe bazot
pour le mei rémy brener sans étiquette
martin buffet pour l'upm thérèse gare et
l eau corinna guyot n'est europe
ecologie les verts marquent mantovani
pour debout la france et cyril man looks
pour le pcf
merci à nos six invités